Not only was Blade a surprise hit for Marvel,
its influence can still be found in some unexpected
places.
To honor that legacy, we're looking at how
Blade changed superhero movies, even if you
didn't always notice.
Marvel characters have been hits on television
since The Marvel Super Heroes cartoon debuted
in 1966.
But film success came much harder.
The first feature based on a Marvel comic
was the infamous 1986 flop Howard the Duck,
and things somehow went downhill from there,
with The Punisher and Captain America both
turned into low budget disasters.
It's enough to make any comic book fan sick.
“Would you please pull over the car, I am
going to get sick."
"Uh, okay, alright."
That changed in the 90's, though, thanks to
Blade, which became a certified hit, earning
over $70 million at the domestic box office.
Marvel itself, however, saw very little benefit
from this financial boom.
Struggling to emerge from bankruptcy in the
late 90's, Marvel only pocketed a measly $25,000
from Blade's success.
But even that had a silver lining.
After earning so little from Blade and other
films like X-Men and Spider-Man, Marvel decided
to make their own film production company
in order to retain all the profits from their
characters.
The result was the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
which may never have existed without Blade.
Writer David S. Goyer has been behind some
of the biggest superhero films ever, with
writing credits on the entire Dark Knight
Trilogy, Man of Steel, and Batman v. Superman:
Dawn of Justice.
But he may never have had the chance to do
those films if not for Blade.
"I wrote a script called Blade, and that script
changed my career completely.
For the first time, I wrote a script without
any editorial interference.”
It worked, and Goyer went on two write all
three films in the Blade Trilogy, even directing
the final installment, Blade: Trinity.
"Take a look at this."
"You gotta be kidding me."
Gloomy vibes.
Night creatures.
Black leather.
Goth was big in the 1980's, but by the 90's,
casual grunge styles, hip-hop culture, and
bright pop colors ruled the day.
Until Blade, that is!
Blade helped usher in a new wave of darker
fare, with a sleek cinematic style that informed
both superhero films and Hollywood in general.
One doesn't need heightened senses to notice
the direct line from Blade to the zombie action
of Resident Evil or the vampire vs. werewolf
battles of the Underworld franchise.
Even The Matrix follows in Snipes' leather-clad
footsteps, both in its shiny black aesthetic
and in its ideas of an underworld waging a
war that humans can't see.
The tagline for the 1978 Superman movie starring
Christopher Reeve boldly declared, "You'll
believe a man can fly."
We did.
But it also helped that everybody in the entire
world already knew who Superman was.
And the same was true of the 1989 mega-hit
Batman.
“I want you to tell all your friends about
me."
"What are you?"
"I'm Batman!"
With other comic book films floundering, conventional
wisdom in Hollywood was that only the biggest
and most famous superheroes could be successful
at the box office.
Blade changed all that.
An obscure cult character even among comic
book fans, the success of the film proved
that even c-list superheroes could be box
office gold if the films were done right.
So if you liked Guardians of the Galaxy or
Doctor Strange, you can thank Blade for blazing
the trail.
Hollywood also had another bit of conventional
wisdom that proved to be a bunch of crap:
the idea that comic book movies were for kids.
Sure, Tim Burton's Batman had a darker aesthetic,
but even that quickly made way for nipple
suits and bad puns.
“What killed the dinosaurs?
The ice age!"
Comic book fans, though, knew that there was
a lot more depth in the source material.
There's a reason DC had to start putting a
"mature readers" label on some of their comics
in the late 80's.
But until Blade, the film world felt that
comic book movies were just silly stuff for
kids.
“Freeze!”
“Motherf----r, are you out of your damn
mind?!"
Blade brought a darker, more grounded sense
of realism and violence to comic book films.
It was the first character from the "Big Two"
publishers, Marvel and DC, to arrive in American
theaters with an R rating.
And its success paved the way not only for
more serious superhero treatments in mainstream
film, but also for a wave of R-rated comic
book films, from Sin City to Deadpool to Logan.
Even Marvel's Netflix shows owe Blade a debt:
look again at Daredevil's hard-hitting punches,
and you might spot a resemblance to Blade's
bloodsucking melees.
Thank you, Blade!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.